every year every federal employee has to
have it's mandatory by government
whistleblower training every single year
and Insider threat training every single
year
and my whole time in in the FBI they
were always separate this year we found
out because thankfully there are still
some good people in the FBI uh that that
training was merged into one so the FBI
didn't even they didn't even say you
know whistleblowing is good and you can
do it like they used to they used to say
yeah it's protected uh now they combine
those trainings overtly saying
whistleblowers are Insider threats I
mean that was the takeaway from the
people we know in the agency who took
that training that slide deck was
released to the public so we can go see
it it's online and it's like okay so the
FBI is not even trying to hide the fact
that they will retaliate against you and
I think that's government-wide look
what's happening with the IRS what's the
blower in his Squad right now but the
FBI has a culture they have had a
culture since Hoover's era of FBI first
no matter what and if you go against the
FBI I can see them we're coming for you
well I applaud you guys for
speaking truth to power right you're
shining light on Justice uh there's a
lot of people that probably do not want
you talking whatsoever who would you say
is at the top of that list what names
what people what institutions are like
Garrett friend get these guys silence
these guys muzzle them right now who's
at the top of that list I I think the
DNC as a whole we we were you know
in-person recipients of that uh at that
hearing the things they were saying the
way they were twisting things and lying
about us and about our whistleblower
status and comparing us to people who
committed Espionage and whatever else
and then uh I think the mainstream media
as well because they're lackeys of the
political Elite and the political Elite
are typically on the left and so uh my
deposition that I went to in February
really stands out for me because I was
led to believe just like I was with my
transfer I was led to believe in good
and I I accepted both in good faith that
everything was kosher so I go to my
deposition a couple weeks later I get a
call from my attorney and he says hey
buddy I got I got some bad news for you
I got a call from CNN and they have your
name and they have some information
about your deposition I was told don't
talk about this deposition unless it's
with a privileged party and so I left
that deposition thinking like I you know
hopefully they will investigate this and
I told them there to the Democrat
attorneys as well who sat in on the
deposition because that's what I agreed
to do because it's not a partisan issue
or it should not be a partisan issue but
we're seeing that it clearly is it's a
right or wrong issue it's like well you
have a soul you you want to just be a
good person you're a Christian and it's
like I'm we talked about this many
podcasts evil right now I don't care
what anybody thinks out there evil is
winning so hard and it's embedded in our
government the governments of the world
and I feel like it's we need people like
you but their their power is so freaking
strong they've all they've all sold
their souls to the devil and the price
is not cheap bro they gotta hold up that
bargain who else would you put on the
list you get the DNC you get the
mainstream media obviously the FBI okay
yeah at the FBI as a whole the ray
certain bureaucrats every other agent
SES level yeah at least or HQ as a whole
most likely okay who would you say yeah
I would agree that the executive levels
and also at the Department of Justice to
um and uh
it even goes down to the the management
structure uh even the ASAC level uh so
assistant special agents in charge that
are still on the GS scale because they
are climbers don't ruin my gig for me so
um I'll name check Colt markowsky and
Sean Ryan as the asacs who sat in the
office for me and when Colt marcott when
I said to him that I took an oath to
protect the Constitution and he
responded back to me you have a duty to
the FBI
that was just a watershed moment for me
I when I took my oath I swore that oath
in front of God and my family and people
who sat around me who I thought were my
friends how uncomfortable is it to
actually name names at this point I I
mean I I wouldn't uh I wouldn't pee on
him if he was on fire
wow here's my question to both of you
since you guys you know were in the FBI
uh do you think because you guys have
come out you're doing this are they
monitoring you guys are they you think
is there a possibility because you guys
will know of anybody are they doing what
they actually do for a living yes are
they tapping you guys some pound they
monitor are they making sure you guys
don't go I mean I don't know the depths
of how how much I'm pretty sure you guys
have information but you think they're
watching you guys I I don't know for
sure but the day I got suspended I had a
very odd thing happened with my phone
while I was talking to an attorney and
it basically cut out and then I couldn't
get back in touch with him and I was
getting an automated message and and
once I did get back in touch with him
and this guy this attorney he's a
retired FBI agent has also and I said
hey uh I explained to him what happened
and he goes oh yeah they probably tapped
the phone who do you think's watching
this right now uh headquarters security
division definitely is I know that that
for a fact I did an interview with them
and they were very tongue-in-cheek about
oh we were big fans of that podcast you
did I was like I'm glad you gave did you
give him a like okay um yeah guys quick
reminder uh like subscribe to Peabody
podcast leave a five star review yeah
yeah going back to what you were saying
when I asked the question about uh the
omerta the code and they trained you
it's FBI Above This you said you know
you got to tell your story what was the
one story you you wanted to share that
was the the he said my my duty was to
the FBI and not to the Constitution do
you have the clip about you know uh
where I believe believe it's um
say which one is it where it says they
will destroy you they will crush you and
your family I think you have the clip if
you can play this clip uh uh uh on yeah
it's that one right there
uh this is um
here is this this is you talking in this
one yeah that's you just play the whole
clip I want the whole thing we have a 20
second one we'll play this one all of
the hardships you've gone through if one
of your really good friends your former
colleagues came to you and said I have
this thing that is being covered up and
I think the American people know to no
need to know about it
what advice would you give them
I'll tell them first to pray about it
long and hard
and I would tell them I could take it to
Congress for them or I could put them in
touch with Congress
but I would advise them not to do it so
you would legitimately try to protect
one of your colleagues from doing what
you have done absolutely
and how do you think that solves being
able to shine light on corruption
weaponization any kind of Mis misconduct
that exists with the American people it
doesn't solve it but the FBI will crush
you this government will crush you
and your family
if you try to expose the truth about
things that they are doing that are
wrong and we are all examples of that I
mean that's pretty powerful I can't
think of a more sobering way to end a
hearing I yield back
so so you would tell them not to so now
if you go back
a year ago and you're having that
conversation with your wife whatever the
timeline is when you when you you
wouldn't have done what you've done
already
uh I'm not saying
if I had a crystal ball I don't know
because how do you sleep at night then
and you know I have four little girl
girls now back then we had three and I
had a conversation with my ASAC at one
point and he was trying to walk me off
the ledge a little bit and I think he
was
he was he was acting like me doing the
wrong thing so just toeing the line
um was caring for my family I think that
that's cowardice and in the Book of
Revelation it tells us that cowards will
be judged uh when when they sit before
the Lord and
how could I then as a man raise my
daughters to be women of integrity and
to do the right thing even when it's
hard if I wasn't willing to do it so I'm
not saying I wouldn't have done it but
uh you know the congressman asked me if
one of my really good friends came to me
with that information Not only would I
do what I answered for a friend I would
do it for somebody that I don't know in
the FBI if if they were were too
unwilling or too afraid to do it but
they knew that they had something that
needed to be brought forward
um
I made that I made my oath many times
twice in the Army once when I reenlisted
um as a police officer as an FBI agent I
meant it and I was willing to stand in
the breach I'm in the breach now so
bring it to me that I'm that's fine I'm
I'm okay with that and we will get it to
Congress or whistleblower attorneys or
wherever it needs to go because the
American people need to know this stuff
yeah there's no question about it that
we need to know this stuff but you know
it ruins lives meaning people like you
it ruins your life and you know Sylvia
Garcia I think was a congresswoman from
California was trying to say you're not
a whistleblower you're not a
whistleblower you're not a whistleblower
I think Debbie Wasserman who comes
across as a total sweetheart from
Florida very good hair you know she was
talking about how this whole thing is
about the book and you're doing you know
just the book and then another lady
comes out and says you know I cannot
believe what you guys are doing this is
defunding the police on steroids she was
the one from U.S Virgin Islands
yeah when she said that so you you see
this stuff obviously this is the part of
discrediting right defund which was
phase one we're suspending you with pay
right if they're suspending you you're
not getting paid no no and it's 7 500
which by the way strategically it's the
dumbest thing to do if you want somebody
to go away and not typically what would
happen in businesses here's a severance
package scientists Nation hold harmless
and move on they do the opposite so
these guys will be terrible in business
they're dummies if they're not doing
this the way to do it is listen we're
going to give you one year this good
luck to you we're sorry it didn't work
out we'll see nothing but the best but
no they cornered you well you have to do
this and come out and talk about it so
also you know running an organization is
not a
wise thing that they're doing so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]